yeah welcome to this video a bit of a
late start your plank reach rapper from
Brazil and I went 46 the Neo Philidor
let's see what he's doing no look we
tried okay so we're going to have one of
those closed maneuvering type games
probably unless he's trying to drop my
queen which sure he's friendly enough to
to announce okay I'd love to play be 50
he actually allows it okay yeah that's
let's do that normally white is some
going for a quick a phone to prevent be
five okay so he wants to play a for now
right desam
yeah the moment done that this happen
night is a bit is clogging up my play a
bit all right um like to play night to
see five but not at the moment okay
let's try to get this exchanged okay
mission accomplished now I have night f4
as a possible idea and 95 95 try to at
the right moment to take the bishop on
b3 hmm not sure maybe he wants to even
play Queen g5 okay let's let's use the
Serb outpost I don't think he really
wants to play g32 to kick it maybe he
just wants to play a queen d 6am and
that's possible
hmm this is I really have have
underestimated Queen to sixty dollars at
x e6 that's a problem
maybe trying for counter play him ok so
I wanted to make sure that after before
it doesn't have night Eve for some chai
him let's see trade this and no I can
play Bishop a6 gaining a temple yeah i
don't think i'm going to do that if it
takes d7 i take it to at the end so i
cannot do that he needs to move the rook
and now maybe 95 or or even rock the
eighth I but he's got 95 ok here of
course still has the Queen d6 idea
hmm don't like it don't like it mmm how
to how to play that yeah all kinds of
stuff is hanging that I'd like to play a
playoff six but okay I mean I end up I'm
in the spin the bishop won't be three
years son just terribly strong yeah it's
not nice not nice at all i'm hoping to
get some counter weight would wait i can
actually try should be seven here this
position yeah yeah yeah it's it's not
enough but it's a bit cut bit of counter
play against you form now look here not
sure yeah okay so i need to prevent a 92
and something like that ok a rock t3t
right take care yeah I only I can only
play for act for activity em know you
sent passive moves the passive moves are
really good but sometimes there's only
am the kind of um yeah sit tight defense
try to keep things together okay just
take it
I can take b-24 not sure I can trust him
maybe he is no way to protect you for
isn't this good for me now even possible
looks like I'll be young I'll be upper
pole at the end and they have the bishop
here we go the question is so yeah the
airport is strong of course can also
take him just probably a draw check
whether i should also play cougar 23
seconds this is not much check
check Gras offered yep I offered it
wrong time morning dr. ok is playing on
time check check check check check yeah
it's just drawn King opponent game now
check check and relax Gail me actually
goes for the draw yeah yeah spend too
much time when I wasn't role and did the
enter there was even though and even the
package at the same game surprisingly
enough roti I should I should definitely
win the money in a minute is plenty of
time I need to somehow keep the the
pieces cannot exchange them but it was
difficult the check is probably the
first wrong step right now the bishop is
Sam is doing a good job here it also
covers super nervous I was also been
panicking him
I should just just activate the kingham
this position you can never play this
because of the check but I somehow as
somehow was in trouble him at least that
it costs lots of time around here maybe
night f4 really was i was a bad idea it
was simply a bit bit too slow probably
maybe I need to start with this this
kind of what I played and then then here
then I'm quick enough i guess to to to
avoid this Queen d6 business something
like that with temple yeah this actually
looks nice maybe I even get that I get
root the Adan this is a comfortable
position I really shouldn't have any
problems after taking on e5 and the
trading of the dark squared bishop but I
got I got into trouble because i played
this check plate this and this
incorrectly yeah I'm struggling a bit
but somehow it wasn't so so so difficult
maybe you shouldn't take and play a play
in other words maybe maybe this one this
could be a good one actually if I go g6
I have weakened f6 a lot maybe something
like that alright thanks for watching